uh we got a call david sheffield and
myself my writing partner we got a call
from brian grazer saying that eddie
murphy wanted to redo the nutty
professor and we'd known eddie for years
uh from saturday night live and he'd
always talked about we doing the nutty
professor and he asked us we'd be
interested and we looked at the film
again and i said well what's eddie going
to play is he going to play
goofy with the teeth and all that stuff
because that doesn't seem like something
you'd want to do and he said no eddie
has a really interesting way of doing it
and then we met with him and he said i
want to do the guy who's heavy and that
despite
no matter he's bright intelligent and
sweet and despite that
all people see us as weight
and to go you want to show the prejudice
people uh
people sometimes get when they're
overweight
and he thought i said then i went well
that's a really good idea something
different so let's do it the hardest
thing that we did was probably the
dinner scene which is one of the funnier
moments in the movie
only because eddie played all five of
the family parts
so in order to do it we did each
character one day at a time
and he shot the whole thing like on a
green screen and talked to tennis balls
so that was that was difficult you know
because we just amassed a lot of film
in the process and then you had to put
it together because you wanted the
characters to be in a two shot rather
than singles you know i mean at one
point
they were saying well you know maybe we
shouldn't make sherman fat you know the
studio is getting scared he's like maybe
she's getting butt teeth like jerry
lewis had eddie playing all the parts
um
he could only be one person
one character a day because of the
makeup time
it took like three and a half hours to
make him up an hour to remove it so you
couldn't do two of those in a day and
still film stuff
so a scene that would normally take
say a day to film
if any played five parts would take five
days
so somebody was like doing the math and
said
let's just have other actors play the
parts you know it'll save a lot of money
and
i
when i heard this i i knew that they
were making a big mistake and i tried to
save them from themselves i called eddie
and said we gotta we gotta do makeups
and show them so
i made eddie up as the mother kept him
in the makeup chair in front of the
mirror and got out my video camera
and uh
started asking questions and
because he said i don't i don't even
know how i'm gonna
how i'm gonna play the mother yet i have
no idea i don't know what to do you know
i'm not really ready to be videotaped
you know i was like well tell me about
your son sherman that's all it takes to
get it started you know and he would try
different voices and see which seemed
like the right thing to come out of that
face
got some hysterical footage and then a
couple days later we made him up as the
grandmother and he knew how he was going
to play that and i think i got something
like four hours of eddie just going off
being a grandmother and
showed some of this footage to your
people that wanted to cut this out of
the movie and said you know you tell me
you want to cut this out
and
they saw what it was going to become and
the fact they took a lot of dialogue
from eddie's
imprint
improvising in the makeup chair and put
it in the movie